you got to get addicted to something
good all addictions are not created
equal
I need little tricks I have little
tricks everybody should do this in their
life ok I want to help the world this is
not taught in schools need motivation
watch the top 10 with believe nation
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from being a kid labeled with a DD
struggling with drug addiction and
almost dying to becoming a best-selling
author sales expert and having real
estate worth over half a billion dollars
he's Grant Cardone
and here's my take on his top ten rules
a success vol 11 also if you want to
know a grant cardone and others have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning short video for free to help you
build your confidence the link to join
is in the description below you have to
go build self-confidence
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get results I was 28 years old three
years sober no drugs in my body for
three years I'm selling cars I'm moving
Toyotas and I'm getting good at it too
like you come in and say look I got bad
credit and I'm not buying today I'm like
goes that's two cars I'm a penalize I'm
a penalize you for saying that boy okay
okay yeah bad you got bad credit
that's perfect at least you got some
credit see I ain't positive I'm there to
get something so so captain Ryan says to
me it's like you're the most positive
person I know I say dude I'm not
positive I'm 10x I get results
okay I want to get the deal done I want
to make my kids proud of me my kids
aren't gonna remember when that was
positive or not they're gonna remember
whether Danny delivered the goodies or
not you understand when you go to Whole
Foods and they said that'll be four
hundred and twenty seven dollars for
three bags and you're like I got a good
attitude
they'd be like you need to get some 10x
you need to get some 10x s and money to
go with your freaking attitude rule
number two get good addictions all the
greats on this planet were addicted to
something Jesus was addicted he's like
hey man I'm gonna do whatever it takes
right or wrong okay you got to get
addicted to something good all
addictions are not created equal okay
I'm addicted to my wife
I'm addicted to my kids I'm addicted to
my purpose I'm addicted to helping out
I'm addicted to making a difference I'm
addicted to doing whatever it takes to
show and be an example of the blessings
that I have rule number three keep
yourself motivated a little trick we do
in our company is we always have
something on our calendar to look
forward to okay if you want to stay
motivated today is what Sunday I always
have something out here out here out
here out here and out here to look
forward to
little short runways that keep me
excited okay I'm going to Turks and
Caicos to shoot a real estate program
when I leave here yesterday I walked out
of here I'm freakin exhausted I'm like
boy I can't wait to get the turks and
caicos see it reenergized right now when
I'm done with that I need something else
to look forward to here I got a whole
bunch of stuff that's gonna happen here
at the end of the month but it's gonna
keep me jacked up when I'm at Turks and
Caicos because the truth is Turks and
Caicos could get a little boring for a
guy like that how many of you have
trouble hat going on vacations you have
trouble unwinding okay you don't even
want to go you're like I can't even
enjoy this so I need little tricks I
have little tricks everybody should do
this in their life okay you need things
to look forward to rule number four do
more
live in today the CNBC in the CNN and
the Netflix be happy just be happy be
satisfied with what you have there's no
push man it's nobody pushing you how
about this you can do more how many of
you can do more oh my god
if that's all you got how many of you
can do more god damned if you know you
can do more if you know you can do more
then you have to do more if you know you
can help if you know you can make a
difference if you don't you're gonna
have this freaking big big hole yeah you
know my no amount of money can fill this
thing up so fill it up rule number five
work on yourself the 30 years since I
left that treatment center I've been
doing one thing studying business I
don't need to worry about my neighbor I
don't need to worry about Trump I don't
need to worry about Obama I don't need
to worry about the Democrats I don't
need to worry about anything until I
worry about these 36 inches man man
people like hey do you believe in aliens
dude I got I'm having trouble with this
all I'm trying to do is expand it over
to here once I do that maybe I can
expand a little bit but I got to get
those six feet under control
I don't criticize other people I'm too
busy criticizing me while I work on my
life I hope other people hate on me and
criticize me I love it it's whew man I'm
like then come up bring it on rule
number six don't chase perfection commit
to getting more done the more you get
done the more you will earn period in
the story why do I get more done because
I post I post without looking at it I
simply get more done why because I'm
committed to getting more done I'm not
I'm not committed to doing it perfectly
these guys all work with me I wish you
could see our studio okay but I got
Francisco here I got Johnny I got Nathan
here I got guys guys do I ever talk
about doing anything perfectly have I
ever said anything about doing something
perfectly I do it I just do I just do a
lot of stuff okay I'm like put that
stuff on the wall there you go that's
good okay look man Johnny's doing the
whole room that's that that's Natalie
there's Nathan okay we got a good group
here right so check it out number one
you got to commit number two you got to
do whatever is in front of you just do
it it doesn't need to be approved it
doesn't need to be checked we're not
hunting like I'm not deer hunting here
I'm not taxi driver and the deer hunter
you know
we're not like I'm not going public here
I'm not trying to raise a billion
dollars I'm just trying to get my damn
job done it's an Instagram post man oh
let me check it oh let me do a filter oh
let me change it let me change the right
rule number seven execute the number one
reason businesses fail is the inability
the inability to sell products in
quantities great enough and at margins
high enough that is the only reason you
will fail you take too long to go from
the idea to selling enough products
volume and margins high enough do that
learn to do that and you can make any
dream a reality
ok I want to help the world this is not
taught in schools there's 8 billion
people on this planet and there's no
shortage of information how many verses
before knowledge is power then why are
so many people suffering why are so many
people suffering nowadays stupid man we
have more information available us today
than at any time in the history of the
world we got too much information at
this point you got too much information
and not enough action rule number eight
seize your opportunities 25 years old
I'm selling automobiles I'm broke I'm in
debt $40,000 in debt spiritually
bankrupt physically bankrupt hate myself
only thing I had was an opportunity the
car dealer that I work for took me back
that was an opportunity don't dismiss
the opportunity you can't go anyplace
without an opportunity no matter how
talented you are no matter how gifted
you are no matter what God has done for
you without an opportunity you will not
move from your garage your life cannot
improve without an opportunity it's
impossible rule number nine master sales
man you guys don't like sales cuz you
ain't got any courage that's why you
want to be a you want to be the vice
president of something that's why you
guys want to call it something else ok
most of you new room don't even have
sales on your card you you sell real
estate for Remax ok or Keller and you
don't even have sales on the card you're
in network marketing you refused
do sales here what do you do then okay
what do you do I mean I think the
company's got a financial statement you
ever read a financial statement what's
the first line on a financial statement
huh what's that first line it's the
first line by the way okay I've seen a
bunch of income statements in my life
the first the first ones are like two
two maybe max four inches long big
companies big giant companies okay I got
five companies they run to one financial
statement in the top line the top line
the sales line you could call it I think
it's called also what revenue could be
called gross revenue okay you know
people are getting confused now okay
they start getting away from this word
some some college guy came in and said
we can't call the sales man we got to
call something like at least two or
three words I mean I went to Harvard
it's not about how much money you make
folks can you use money can you use it
okay look just top these top lines right
here are about income if you hate sales
you hate income and rule number ten the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is don't think small I don't care
who you are I don't care what your age
is okay I spent the first from the age
of twenty five years old to forty five
years so I spent twenty years thinking
small thinking small and taken too long
I built three little businesses they
were all doing good man they were doing
good three of them man from scratch
first little business I was a
millionaire when I was thirty 33 years
old punching shoving hard work man the
more money I had the more scared I was
because I had just enough money to be
scared as soon as you get a million
dollars you're gonna go into terror
I'm telling you gonna be like what am I
gonna do now
okay I wasn't scared before now I got
something to lose that's why you never
want to get your advice from a
millionaire if you're taking notes never
get your advice from a millionaire ever
okay this held me down for 20 years 20
years it held me down you look at
I read The Millionaire Next Door what
did The Millionaire Next Door say buy a
used truck and don't go to Starbucks you
say 4 bucks a day for the next 38 years
you will be in heaven
no you ain't you gonna be stupid it's
dumb man okay if $4 is gonna break you
on any given day you're just back to
thinking the way you were thinking when
you didn't have anything buy everything
on sale okay everything you're gonna buy
is gonna be on sale you got to get a
deal every time you buy something is
that what your daddy taught you never
pay retail for anything that means
nobody will ever pay you retail folks
now I've got a special bonus clip from
grant on how to turn your life around
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
answer these questions in the comments
below here we go question number one how
are you thinking small right now number
two what is a 10x version of your idea
look like and number three what's the
good addiction that will help get you
there
I was 23 years old I was beaten within
inches of my life I had 76 stitches put
in my head and face because I had made
nine years of bad choices my dad died
when I was 10 years old I think that
there's an epidemic in this country
where where families are missing a
father I know for me I was a good kid I
grew up in a middle-class family my mom
and my dad were very responsible
hard-working people I didn't get beat up
there was no alcoholism there was no
drug addiction I did not get brought up
the way Kanye West did Kanye he's got
excuses I didn't have in it and there's
a whole bunch of kids in America they
don't have any excuses but they don't
have a purpose they don't have an
opportunity and they don't have anything
to do and that was me when my dad died I
was 10 years old and from 10 to 16 when
I should have been experiencing grief
you know and and and I was angry about
it how many of you had a loss before and
you got angry about it customer doesn't
buy from you God doesn't show up you get
angry angry is not a response to the
situation and then when somebody sits on
anger for long enough what happens is
without a purpose without a purpose an
individual is going to go arrey no
matter how good they are they're going
to go off and do other things and so by
the time I was 16 years old I had a drug
problem but by the time I was 20 years
old I was using drugs every single day
and by the time I was 23 I was carrying
a gun every day worried I was going to
get killed every day had a college
degree 17 years I've spent in school the
more month the more college I got the
less money I had and the more trouble I
ended up here okay
23 years old I get beat I'm in a
hospital my mom comes to a hospital she
looks at me and says but where's my son
okay that was me not too long ago
doesn't seem like it was that long ago
and today LegalShield has me to speak to
you today
and they I tell you that to tell you
like anybody can come back I don't care
how old you are how young you are what
color you are what your problems are
anybody can come back yeah the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon
[Music]
if you want more grand check out the top
50 rules video I did on him the link is
right there next to me I think you're
really gonna enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there you
cannot skate you cannot outsource
everything this idea that you're going
to be a solopreneur outsource or work
for hours or part-time